have you taken the red pill that means
not taking the blue pill and waking up
to the fact that what you've been told
is often raw you take the blue pill the
phrase comes from the movie The Matrix
believe whatever you want to believe you
take the red pill you stay in Wonderland
and I show you how deep the rabbit-hole
goes
that moment in the matrix Morpheus is
offering him simply the truth
Candace Olin says she took the red pill
and now her YouTube channel offers red
pills to millions of others people don't
care to watch CNN anymore people are
paying attention to youtubers okay my
second video when trending worldwide
with 80 million views
80 million 80 million it's obviously the
media's fault in that video she mocked
the media for finding racism everywhere
the persistence of racism in America the
surge of hate the online racism CNN was
trying to sell to me as a black person
that the KKK was alive and well that was
ridiculous
oh my god charlottesville white
supremacy is alive and well so I made a
video just essentially making fun of the
narrative how ridiculous that I should
be scared to go outside because the KKK
is alive and well another bully shooting
of a black team she also complains that
the media imply the biggest threat to
young blacks is the police police
officer charged with murder caught on
camera shooting an unarmed black man
that's number one approximately 93
percent of black homicide victims are
killed by other black people police
violence is a real threat no it is not
and I will not allow you to say that
either it is not a real threat if some
innocent people have been tortured by
police that's absolutely right some
innocent people have also been struck by
lightning 16 unarmed black men were
killed by police officers in 2016 if you
are watching CNN you would have thought
it was happening every single day okay
that's a problem 16 represents point
zero zero zero zero four percent of the
black community and yet there were riots
and there were protests and black lives
matter has actually resulted in more
black
deaths across the country because police
officers don't want to answer the call
it's not popular in the black community
to say such things or to say that you
are conservative Owens jokes in this
video that it's easier to tell your
parents you're gay mom dad I'm a lesbian
I like girls Oh sweetheart we always
knew oh thank you guys
oh also I think I might be a
conservative guys it's totally fine it's
okay I just you know think a little more
conservatively sweethearts mom I'm still
black I simply think that we should
maybe put the economical future of this
country ahead of the social issues that
is all sweetie can you please just be
gay it's more difficult to say to
someone I'm a conservative Candace says
the big issue facing blacks is not
racism or police shootings its
dependence on government that began 50
years ago with Lyndon Johnson's Great
Society programs they incentivized
mothers right to not to marry their
fathers single that's why single
motherhood is up the government would
give you more if you didn't marry him we
are fully reliant on the government my
entire family is on welfare save a
couple of people and what it does is
they essentially offer you some money
and then they say wherever you work okay
you don't make enough so we're gonna
give you this much money on top of that
so they they do what they say oh I don't
want to make more because the government
is already giving me giving me five
hundred that I don't want to lose and
your entire family's on welfare
yeah pretty much my entire family's on
welfare and they still like you yeah
they love me oh great great
Oh celebrities now I really think about
Raja fear absolutely dominates black
people like hamsters on a wheel what the
government has done successfully is made
people insecure people don't think they
can do anything without the government
we've got the government regulating nail
salons eyebrow salon the government has
extended an overreach into every single
arena of our lives the time is now for
black lines to be unleashed people don't
understand is how many black people are
so excited about what I'm doing
how many black people see the
opportunity and how many black people
are very aware that they have been duped
by the left she calls that taking the
red pill
who else has taken the red pill Brandon
Tatum he's got a pretty large following
your success in life is dependent upon
you
there's CJ Pearson who says he's the
left's youngest problem black lives they
do matter
so do why lies that I think why some of
these black conservatives have not been
successful in the past is because they
care too much about what people thought
we're doing it differently we are
talking a lot of trash we are very sassy
the african-american community is
suffering from the poor memory when you
want people to know you can feel free to
call me and Uncle Tom you can feel free
to call me an auntie Tom it does not
affect to me do you want to know why
they actually read the book and Uncle
Tom is the hero